التاكيد ياتي من اسبانيا ليونيل ميسي الى
الهلال ومعه صديقيه مانشستر يونايتد في
مرمى سخريه السوشيال ميديا تيك توك تنشر
محادثه مسجله هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها
لكم عبر قناه العربيه رياضه واسعدوا
لمتابعتكم
يبدو ان الايام القليل القادمه ستحمل
اخبارا سعيده تعوض الهلاليين خساره نهائي
دوري ابطال اسيا برنامج الشرنجيتال
الاسباني اكد اليوم منح الارجنتيني ليونيل
ميسي موافقته للهلال السعودي على اللعب له
الموسم القادم عقب نهايه عقده مع باريس
سان جيرمان الفرنسي البرنامج لم يوضح اي
تفاصيل خاصه بمده او قيمه العقد الا انه
اشار ان ميسي لن يصل الرياضه وحده بل معه
سيرجي بوش عقب نهايه عقده مع برشلونه الى
جانب جوردي البا في حاله توصل لاتفاق مع
الفريق الكاتلوني على فسخ عقده معه
بالتراضي
والى انجلترا حيث تحول مانشستر يونايتد
الى ماده للسخريه في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي عقب تعثره امام وست هام في
الدوري المحلي انعش بها امال ليفربول في
الفوز بمقعد مؤهل لدوري ابطال اوروبا هذه
النتيجه ارتفعت موقعا امريكيا لنشر صوره
ساخره لجدول ترتيب البريميرليج كتب عليها
هذا هو حال ليفربول وهو يشاهد سقوط
مانشستر يونايتد رامي عباس وكيلو اعمال
محمد صلاح لعب ليفربول قرر المشاركه في
حمله السخريه بان اعاد نشر التغريده واضاف
ايموجي ضاحك يعبر عن سخريته من جدول
الترتيب
نتحول الى الجابوني اوباميانغ ومقطع
الفيديو المسجل للاعب تشيلسي الانجليزي
الذي تم تداوله عبر السوشيال ميديا صحيفه
سبورت الاسبانيه اكدت ان مشجعا التقى مع
اوباميانغ في احدى المحلات وساله عن
برشلونه اجابه الدولي الغابوني اظهرت
رغبته في الانتقال الى النادي الكاتولوني
الموسم المقبل وشعوره بالندم من انتقاله
الى البلوز خاصه انه لا يشارك اساسيا في
تشكيله
33 عاما لم يكن يدرك حينها ان حديثه الودي
يتم تسجيله من قبل المشجع الفضولي الذي
نشر الحديث عبر منصه التيك توك
الختام مع صديقه لاعب الجولف المحترف
تايجر السابقه واتهامها الرسمي له بالتحرش
الجنسي اريكا ادعت اجبارها على توقيع
اتفاقيه عدم افشاء والا سيتم فصلها من
وظيفتها في مطعم يملكه ودز عملت فيه
كموظفه ووفقا لوثيقه قدمها محاميها
للمحكمه في فلوريدا وبحسب هذه الوثيقه فان
ودز خرع خدع ايريكا لمغادره منزلها وحبسها
واخذ اموالها وحيواناتها الاليفه
وممتلكاتها الشخصيه واجبرها على توقيع
اتفاقيه عدم الافشاء وعلى ذمه محامي
هيرمان فان هذه الاتفاقيه الموقعه عام
2017 تعتبر غير قابله للتنفيذ جزئيا بسبب
القانون الجديد الذي يبطل بنود التحكيم في
قضايا الاعتداء او التحرش الجنسي
[موسيقى]